ready her story as the collection of
game mechanics is not complicated you
sit at an old school computer browsing
through a clunky police database
watching videos of a woman from 1994
what is complicated though is the way
the story unravels within the game in a
nonlinear fashion it's the combination
of those two which makes the game so
good the central game mechanic isn't
there to trick you you enter a word or
phrase in inverted commas and any video
matching those terms will pop up for
your viewing pleasure of course
eventually you have to get a little
smarter about what you're searching
since the ancient computer system will
only dole out the first five videos in
chronological order but finding and
watching the majority of the clips isn't
the real hurdle the real task lies in
piecing together the narrative from the
dozens of bits you discover in your own
random order there are any number of
ways to interpret and link each video to
one another which means there's many
paths you can take as you try to piece
out the story to create a whole the game
may begin with the word murder slung
into the search bar but where you go and
what you discover from there is entirely
up to you it's a tricky thing for a
narrative based game to decide to go
nonlinear you risk alienating people who
find it tough from the start or
delivering a jumble of nonsense to
people who don't put the effort in but
her story puts a lot of trust in us it's
like exercise you get out what you put
in with a game this unstructured that
can mean putting in an awful lot it
means getting out a notepad jotting down
key words and drawing mind maps using
the in-game video tagging tool all
lining up several videos in a sequence
to get a better
understanding of what's really going on
herstory trusts its players to make the
effort and from everybody I've spoken to
who's played this game more often than
not they do in the same way that
difficult games like Dark Souls or Super
Meat Boy or mechanically vague ones like
the vanishing of Ethan Carter trust that
you'll keep trying and ultimately work
it out her story does the same there's
nothing to suggest that there's a right
or wrong way to go about your
investigation through the police
archives even if you watched every one
of the 270 videos in the database it's
not necessarily an indicator of how much
of the story you've actually compendious
given this is a narrative driven game
unraveling and getting your head around
the story is the ultimate puzzle if
you've ever seen a cop show you
understand how the interrogation process
works
her story enables you to play detective
but with some intentional missing pieces
to make it all the more engaging you
can't ask your own questions since
you're watching archived videos and you
can't corroborate evidence you don't get
to hear the questions the interrogating
detectives at the time asked which
sometimes leads to a frustratingly
one-sided conversation
the woman's opinions reactions and her
story is the only information you have
to go on and it's up to you to discern
the truth from the lies and use your own
personal logic to figure out exactly
what happened it's a refreshing change
from the hand-holding tutorials and
objective markers of modern games that
worry way too much about whether we'll
get lost or confused and lose interest
in playing her story is special because
it's a game of chewy-cheese truth and
lies victims and perpetrators simple
game mechanics and complicated narrative
structures it trusts us with its
complexity and pushes the boundaries of
what video games are and could be and if
all that sounds like your thing it's
well and truly worth your 6 bucks